موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله اتهم الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالدو
باستهدافه بتهم زائفه وملفقه في قضيه
الاحتفاظ بوثائق السريه وقال امام حشد من
منصار مناصريه في ولايه نيوجيرسي ان
محاكمته في تلك القضيه تعتبر تدخلًا
ومحاوله اخرى لتزوير وسرقه الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله واعتبر ان محاكمته فيدرل
فيدراليا هي سوء استغلال شرير وشنيع
للسلطه
وكانت رب قد مثلا في الجلسه الاولى
لمحاكمته في قضيه الوثائق السريه في ميامي
بولايه فلوريدا حيث دفع محاميه ببراءه
ترامب من عشرات التهم بينها عرقله العداله
وحيازه وثائق سريه وانتهاك قانون التجسس
خلصت نتائج تحقيقات الجيش الاسرائيلي في
عمليه معبريه العوجه الحدودي مع مصر الى
وجود عده اخفاقات في الجاهزيه العسكريه
وقد حملت مسؤوليه الخسائر لقائد الفرقه
الاسرائيليه على الحدود وقرر الجيش
الاسرائيلي وسد الممرات الامنيه المقامه
في السياج الحدودي على طول الحدود مع مصر
افدى مراسل الجزيره بان معارك استخدمت
فيها الاسلحه الثقيله دارت امس بين الجيش
وقوه الدعم السريع قرب المنطقه الصناعيه
وفي حيي الرميله والحله الجديده غرب
العاصمه الخرطوم كما سمع دوي انفجارات في
ام درمان وشهد تصاعد لاعمده الدخان وتحليق
للطائرات الحربيه في سماء مدن الخرطوم
الثلاث
نقلت عن مسؤول في الخارجيه الامريكيه قوله
ان طرفي الصراع في السودان لا ينتهزان
محادثاته جده التي اوتيحت لهما واوضح
المسؤول الامريكي ان محادثات جدا لا تحقق
نجاحا فيما يتعلق بالتوصل لوقف دائم
للقتال بالسودان ونقلت رويترز ايضا عن
مسؤول الخارجيه هي الامريكيه اعلانه ان
واشنطن تتشاور مع الرياض وشركاء اخرين
بشان السودان وتتوقع اعلان نهج جديد
اعرب الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيريش عن قلقهم ما وصفه بالبعد القبلي
المتزايد للعنف في دارفور وجدد غوتريس
وفقا ما نقل عنه المتحدث باسمه ستيفان دو
جاريك دعوته للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
وقوات الدعم السريع لوقف القتال والالتزام
بوقف دائم للاعمال الغذائيه
اكد الرئيس الروسي وفلاديمير بوتين ان على
بلاده محاربه من وصفهم بعملاء العدو واضاف
بوتين في لقاء مع مراسلين عسكريين مؤيدين
للكرملين انه كان بالامكان الاستعداد بشكل
افضل للهجمات على المناطق الحدوديه
الروسيه ولوحى انه اذا استمرت الهجمات فعل
روسيا التفكير في ايجاد منطقه عازله داخل
اوكرانيا
قال المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ان الجيش يحقق مزيدا من التقدم في عمليته
في باخموت وبيغنس واضاف المتحدثون القوات
الاوكرانيه استعاده السيطره على نحو سته
كيلومترات ونصف في منطقه تي عمليات دنيا
كشفت صحيفه
من المتوقعين ان تزود اداره بعيدا
اوكرانيا بقنابل اليورانيوم المنظم ونقلت
عن بعض المسؤولين الامريكيين هدفهم هو
تمكين اوكرانيا من تحقيق اكبر قدر ممكن من
التقدم في صحه المعركه هذا وقال رئيس
بيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكاشينكو انه لن يتردد
في استخدام السلاح النووي اذا تعرضت بلاده
لاي اعتداء واوضح انه هو من طلب من بوتين
نشر هذه الاسلحه التي اعتبرها وسيله للربا
اعلنا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن عن حزمه مساعدات امنيه جديده
لاوكرانيا بقيمه
325 مليون دولار تتضمن مزيدا من الاسلحه
والمعدات بهدف دعم القوات الاوكرانيه
انتهى المجازا ما كنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل
خير
[موسيقى]